if you've been following me for a while
you may have noticed i am a massive
nerd and honestly i have always been
this way
my favorite pastime activity from the
beginning of time
has basically been reading and although
i am sure you can imagine how wildly
popular this made me in school
thank god that today we have people like
jack who make absolute nerds like me by
association
seem vaguely cool so today if you want
to join the mega nerds club
welcome i will try to explain how to
fall in love with books by explaining
why i think i am so in love with books
the reason i am doing this is because i
realize that so much of
my achievements have come purely from
reading and so many successful people
attribute their success to reading so
today i'm going to share seven reasons
why i'm in love with reading and
implementing any of these should
hopefully
make this journey a lot easier for you
if you are looking to do the same
so let's get started the first one is
that no one actually ever
made me read so i never had negative
associations with
books at all it was purely something
that i wanted to do
and most importantly i think the best
thing for this is that because no one
told me what to read no one also told me
what not to read i was allowed to see
anything that i wanted and anything that
i was interested in
so this always made reading a huge
pleasure for me what's quite funny is
that when i had to read things like for
school
i often would not read the books that i
needed to read in literature i would
just read their summaries
online on wikipedia because if i didn't
find the book interesting
i would just not read it so that meant
that i always associated it with
something that was fully fun
and that i was fully in control of so i
think firstly realizing that you are
doing this for yourself
and not because someone else tells you
tells you or because it's just
a good thing to do is a good way to
start with it and second thing is that i
always follow my interests with books
and i very often
go down rabbit holes if i find something
interesting i will very guiltlessly read
it i've
read completely trashy books i've read
classics i've read
books about deriving physical formulas
so literally anything that i really care
about i go where my interests
take me when i was younger a huge amount
of what i read would just be
encyclopedias and i would go from one
encyclopedia to the next to the next to
the next and just
read a whole book about mummification in
ancient egypt and then go down another
rabbit hole and read about the process
of mummification on the body and then go
down another rabbit hole and read about
human biology and then go down another
rabbit hole and read about the specific
organ
so i think just following what interests
you and going down that rabbit hole
is such an easy way to read more and
find reading fun and my third point it
kind of feeds on that and that is always
going back to first principles
if i read one book it may be one chapter
or even one sentence in a book that
really really resonates with me a great
example of this are stephen hawking's
books on the universe
so i will read something about black
holes for example and it will have a
formula which really resonates with me
and i think oh this is really cool what
is the physics behind this so then i'll
go to a physics textbook and read about
that
and then i'll go into a deeper physics
textbook like a university book
that talks about that specific maths i
know this is super nerdy and not what
i'm recommending for
anything this is just because i'm really
into physics but let's say you are into
literature
you can go down the same rabbit holes
with different authors you can go down
these rabbit holes with history
you can easily go down these rabbit
holes with archaeology literally
anything you are interested in and it
only takes one thing that can prompt you
for what book to go to next and you can
easily
form a reading list for yourself super
super simply the first point is that i
don't really care
about what is hot at the minute or what
is cool for example i never read 50
shades of grey or twilight or the hunger
games
if a book doesn't interest me it just
doesn't and because it's mainstream may
mean that it's more accessible but if it
doesn't resonate with you
i think that it can add to you not
liking books if you're trying to read
what all your friends are reading and
saying is great
and is not right you might feel that oh
i guess i'm just not a reader then but
that's not necessarily the case so i
sometimes think that avoiding mainstream
books might actually be a good idea
and finding your niche or finding people
with whom you resonate with especially
online that's super easy to do now and
see what their favorite books are you're
much more likely to
find books that are more related to you
for example i've read time enough for
love it's a very niche book which is now
one of my favorite books and i heard it
on a podcast
of someone on tim ferriss so it was just
this one scientist on tim ferriss with
whom i thought oh
i really love this and um yeah that's
how i get my book recommendations
rather than going to like the top
bestsellers on kindle for example
which i might actually not find that
cool my fifth point is that i
reread books a lot i don't really care
about how many books i read as a number
and my goal isn't to kind of just read
as much as possible
my goal is to have as much fun as
possible and sometimes a book is so good
that i will want to read it like a
hundred times i remember when i was
younger i
definitely did this with harry potter so
i read each of the harry potter books
seven times each and i would just go
through them again
and again and again especially when i
was waiting for the new books to come
out
shout out to anyone who is from that
generation but i think this is a huge
recommendation of mine if you're just
not finding new books that you like
or if you haven't read in a long time
what is a book from your childhood that
you really enjoyed a book that you read
a long time ago that you really enjoyed
just go back to it because it doesn't
just have to be new books
although i do get fomo and i wish i
could live forever so that i could read
every book in the world it doesn't
really matter if i like something i will
reread it i will enjoy it again and
again
i felt so reassured when i heard nabal
which is one of the people that i
respect the most in my life um saying
that he sometimes goes halfway through
the book before he realizes that he's
read it before
and i honestly felt the same but i felt
so stupid for saying it out loud
as though people might judge me that
well you clearly haven't read it well
enough the first time
but genuinely what he said is that when
you reread a book
and um then only later you realize that
you've read it before it's because it's
the right time for you to reapproach
this
and for the book to come into your life
and that's kind of the way that i see it
now
so both unintentionally and
intentionally i will read books again
and again
and re-enjoy them especially when i know
that it's a guaranteed pleasure for me
to read
just go back to it this can be novels
educational books anything really my
sixth point is that i take a lot of
notes
although i kind of recommend this to
everyone i know that it's also something
advanced and i'm
massively over the top with this in that
i literally have a second brain
and i um take notes of everything that i
read
to a huge extent i just find this a lot
of fun because it means that i can
reapply a lot of what i learn it's much
less likely for me to forget that i've
read that book
and also i can take the applications and
the notes and use them in other things
such as this video i'll show something
from a book later in this video
and also other things i produce i will
often pull information from those books
and connect them with each other
so note taking kind of means that you're
more active in engaging with the book
you're more active in general than just
possibly getting information
so definitely something that i would
recommend and the seventh point is that
i don't feel guilty about my approach at
all
sometimes i usually have three four five
maybe even ten books that i'm reading
at once in a way sometimes it takes me
one afternoon to read a book
sometimes i read two three different
books at different points in the day
sometimes i will sit down and binge read
a book very very slowly for
a week and read nothing else in that
time i just read
the way that i feel and kind of it's i
feel that it is my space to be
free and creative and whatever i feel
like doing in the moment is what i will
do
with as little guilt as possible so i
think in general it's just ties to
everything that i said
making it pleasurable will make it more
likely that you enjoy it
and one way to make it pleasurable is to
remove these obligations
you don't have to read shakespeare if it
genuinely doesn't resonate with you
it might not be right for you right now
and you don't need to read mainstream
books
and you don't need to finish every book
that you read if you want to make it
more fun for yourself
just doing what you feel like in the
moment when you feel like it will be the
best and i just wanted to
um add one one quote from allah in his
book on how perhaps can change your life
which kind of says something along the
lines that the reason that we might feel
lonely
is because our experiences are so
scattered
among the world there's actually a lot
of people who might be feeling very
similarly to how you feel
but not all of them are alive right now
not all of them
are in your vicinity and not all of them
are even expressing these things to you
but reading books can unlock so many
people who are going through the same
thing
that it just kind of makes you not feel
alone and
also gives you so much pleasure in
connecting with the universe and with
life
in a way that is so private but also
so communal that it's absolutely
ridiculous so
yeah on that note those were my top
recommendations
on how to make yourself fall in love
with books i honestly hope that this was
helpful in any shape or form
i would love i would genuinely
absolutely love
any sort of book recommendations that
you think might be a fit for me
or that you particularly enjoy a lot but
yeah thank you so much for spending this
time with me i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day
behind yourself and others and don't
believe everything you think bye
you